hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to greetings now this game
was made in the game jam and it's
supposedly spooky horror really dark boy
really dark and gritty and exceptionally
detailed oh my god this actually looks
good I don't know why it's got in store
for me but I'm gonna go charge bravely
into the darkness I just hope for the
best cuz I know anybody home anybody
wanna mess with me hi how's it going
this seems like a trap I'm just gonna go
ahead and say that now this seems like a
trap I just get spawned in in a
mysterious Space Station and I don't
know what I'm doing or where I'm going
seems honestly like a trap where are you
taking me where am i what is this place
what's still wibblewobble in my ears I
don't know just looks like a like a
level in doom which I wouldn't mind if
it had a little bit of do mess into it
but I don't think I'm gonna be that
little hi what are you doing here why
are you here
nice ass hello funny okay
you [ __ ] kidding me what are you
[ __ ] kidding me thousand that was it
the entire experience just say hello oh
you sack of [ __ ]
ha ha you sack of [ __ ] oh my god
this might be the shortest let's play
I've ever done in my life even video
game the game wasn't shorter than this
let's play stupid I feel terrible but
Meyer your charm all right so I couldn't
leave you guys with such a short let's
play so you give me double feature today
I've got Mouse simulator which was a
game that I was like I don't know if
it'll be good so I guess we're gonna
find out oh man anyway so oh my god oh
this game is atrocious or I shouldn't be
so negative this game is amazing oh look
jeez Oh dad I'm not damn it am i oh jeez
okay now I'm dead Jordi's let's play
never so funny
oh my god that is so [ __ ] oh there's
another one right there
alright let's not do that I can't jump
oh that's oh look at my oh man okay oh
hi hello hi how's it going ooh okay I'm
right here
hello Wow you evil person is horrible oh
my god okay well I found all the way to
die oh let's try to actually please okay
bye hello okay what's with the music why
does this game what does this game need
heavy metal playing in the background
this isn't doom this is a mouse
simulator it's not that intense no what
am I trying to do here excuse me uh
pardon me pardon moi
hi okay can i sprint no I just gotta get
out of here for looming shadow of death
I'm just gonna scooch on here you can't
no you don't you don't see nobody all
right oh that is that is oh that's
downright terrified don't please oh look
is that food oh good I think
Hey okay all right supposed to do the
run away Oh which was your cheer now
what's going on with your mouth they're
dead end oh yeah oh that's no good
I have subtly mean of you don't even try
it
don't even try do it oh I don't know
where to go I think I'm lost
oh I might be cornered I'm gonna starve
to death I have no chance no joke I'm
gonna die I'm assuming that's my hunger
bar I have nothing to base that on but
the only thing my gamer instinct tells
me that is is hunger see this is why I
didn't want to play this one like by
itself but I guess the opportunity
presented itself alright so anyway that
is the end of this two-parter mouse
emulator and greetings both amazing
games that I love very much about that
actually made me laugh a lot but for
different reasons I think they intended
but either way thank you everybody so
much for watching hope you enjoy this
small double feature even is normal like
two games still one of the shortest
Let's Plays I've ever done but hey
that's just the way it is so thank you
again let me know what you thought these
game down the comments below I'll put
links in the description why not and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]